Hey there, can
you show me your student handbook
? Ah,
why is your hair color and other things violating the school rules?
I didn't know about it because I was just resisting it, but
I can't tell the other students who opened it with shyness.
Make-up first button Undesignated ribbons
Brush accessories Tight shin bag
Skirt length is all a violation of blockage
Haha
.
It doesn't matter, it's there
, hit it already
High speed is one of social studies that follows the rules set in school Is
everyone here under the same conditions If you go to
this academy,
you follow the rules
It's not strange that I've been healthy I'm in a white cotton room
That's the same place at the back
[music]
Yes, it's a change in the student council president
Look, I can't argue
[music]
ni
me
From tomorrow I'll
protect everything
[music]
voodoo
now is important